[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
man
[Music]
what's up guys bang bang
welcome to the best business show
my team and i've been working on this
for a while now we are
super excited to bring this to you there
is a massive problem in the world
there is a complete lack of financial
education at the same
exact time that young people around the
world have started to become interested
in investing in business and financial
markets
the mainstream media the wealthy the
elite the incumbents on wall street
are mocking and ridiculing these young
people well rather than doing that we
think the better solution
is to simply educate them to show them
how to build
a life of wealth that will ultimately
bring them financial freedom
there is one difference between rich
people
and poor people that is the main driver
of wealth inequality
in the united states and around the
world it's education
rich people know something that those in
the bottom 45 to 50 percent
don't know and we're going to take do
our best to do that
i'm not doing it alone i'm here with my
brothers joe and
john how do you know they are joe and
john well it's easy
they literally have their names on there
chairs that's right they're here they're
going to help me they've got all kinds
of great
data facts a couple of jokes here and
there they may not be as pretty as me
but they're way way smarter
so they're gonna do it before we get
started if you're watching this on
youtube
please like the video so more people
will see it make sure you're subscribed
to the channel we're gonna be going live
every day from 11 00
to 1 p.m eastern if you're on
twitter make sure you retweet it you
comment
do whatever you want use best business
show all right
we're going to get into it the number
one thing that is going
on in the world today that seems to be
completely
ignored by the mainstream and by the
incumbents
is inflation is getting out of control
last year we were told inflation wasn't
going to happen
now we are being told it's transitory
but
people don't understand inflation
and so we're going to walk through
exactly how it works why it's important
what it means for you and why you
literally are making less money
today than you were making a decade ago
up until the end of 2019 we had been in
a decade-long bull market
we had seen stocks explode upwards most
assets
had continued to rise and people felt
like they were geniuses
because all of the assets in their
portfolio were going up but we started
to see
lots and lots of warning signs inverted
yield curves
tons of ceos leaving their jobs
gyrations
in the repo markets etc which are just
signs of the end
or near the end of some sort of bull
market
nobody knows when what it's going to end
nobody knew what was going to create the
end
but there were signs that we were
getting close to the end
and then covid happened and kovid made
the world economy
the u.s economy screeched to a halt the
velocity of money
the amount of commerce that was
happening completely fell off a cliff
the government
forced people to go sit at home and when
they did that and the velocity of money
went near zero
people got scared and in march 2020
there was a liquidity crisis and that
liquidity crisis
ended up leading to one of the greatest
sell-offs and assets
in the last decade and so what is the
liquidity crisis it simply means that
people are uncertain they're fearful of
the future
they don't know what's going to happen
it seems like things are really bad
the government's making me sit at home i
can't go to my job there's
six million people or more a week for
multiple weeks firing for first-time
unemployment claims
stuff is messed up around the world what
do i do
well i have assets so i look around my
portfolio and i say to myself
i want cash cash is safe let me get us
dollars i look at my stocks
i can sell them i sell them there's gold
i have it
i can sell it i sell it bitcoin i have
it i can sell it i sell it commodities i
have them i can sell it i sell it
everything gets sold off and people run
for dollars the dollar becomes stronger
it becomes more
sought while those asset prices sold off
when this happens the u.s government
politicians
and the federal reserve the treasury et
cetera they have a decision
they can simply allow the free market to
play out they can say
we are not going to intervene in markets
or
they can do what they did which is they
can intervene in the market now the us
economy
and the global economy is like a drug
addict we now are at a situation
where the economy is dependent on
monetary stimulus
we cannot operate the economy
without having constant intervention the
politicians
the federal reserve etc has completely
banned market corrections
and outlawed bear markets and what i
mean by that
is that every time we start to see any
sort
of bear market or market correction like
in march of 2020
they step in and they inject massive
liquidity into the market
and so over the last 12 to 18 months
the u.s economy has seen more than 5
trillion dollars injected into it
trillions and trillions more dollars
globally all that means
is that they created money they found
ways to take liquidity or cash
and inject it into the market they did
this by giving extra boost to people on
unemployment
they did this by giving risk-free loans
to tons and tons of businesses
they found every possible way whether it
was an exotic method
or an elementary method to inject
liquidity into the economy
the government was here to save us but
what happens
is that the economy eventually opened
people started to go back to work
people started to go back outside
they're now going to concerts they're
going to the movie theaters they're
going out
to eat at restaurants but all of that
monetary stimulus that got created that
got thrown into the economy
is now causing a devaluation of the
dollar
the dollar is worth less today than it
was
a year ago what does that mean it simply
means that if you have a dollar
a year ago versus today that dollar buys
you less goods
the cost of things in your life are
going up
whether it's gas construction materials
food
or anything else the cost is going up
because the dollar
is worth less and so that is why they
said don't worry inflation isn't going
to be a big deal
now they're saying it's transitory oh we
are only seeing a transitory amount of
inflation
inflation is the measurement of change
over the last year right
but the problem is that as we're seeing
prices being hyped up
tyson foods tyson is a 30 billion dollar
food distribution company in q1 of this
of 2021 of this year they reported
the average cost or the average price of
an item that they sell
they increased seven and a half percent
if you wanted to buy a product from
tyson foods
the average price increase that you saw
was seven and a half percent
q1 the cost of gasoline in many places
is over
five dollars the cost of houses have
exploded
not all of this is due to inflation some
of it is due to disruptions in supply
chains
housing shortages etc but at the end of
the day
what we found is that majority
of americans feel like they cannot get
ahead
i'm going to read you some statistics as
to how bad the financial education
system
or environment is today in america 66
of american families don't have savings
that are equivalent to
six weeks of expenses 78 percent of
adults
live paycheck to paycheck almost 80
percent
of the population lives paycheck to
paycheck
80 percent of young people couldn't
answer majority of the financial
literacy questions on a test
accurately 54 percent of millennials
are concerned about their student loan
debt student loan debt in this country
is over 1.5
trillion dollars now and less than 20
percent of adults less than one in every
five
feel confident about their savings
habits we have a problem
and at the same time that we have made
an absolute mockery of markets by
manipulating them and injecting
liquidity into them
all of these young people started to pay
attention they started to realize
you cannot save your way to wealth
anymore in this country
they have destroyed the ability to save
saving is for losers that is the hard
truth
you were probably told by your parents
or your grandparents
save save spend less than you make and
some of that is true
you should spend less than you make you
should make sure you get out of debt but
you cannot
save your way to wealth anymore and the
reason is because the
dollar today is worth less than it used
to be
and what you find is that here is the
key difference between wealthy people
and those that are not wealthy the
wealthy people
know how to profit from inflation they
know how to benefit
and so in the same time that we saw
millions and millions and millions of
americans around the country
going to the unemployment line we also
saw
massive wealth creation for those that
held investable assets
the stock market is up over 35
over the last 12 months the top 55
percent of americans
have investments they hold investable
assets the bottom 45 percent of
americans
hold no investable assets that's the
difference that is the wealth inequality
gap
is if you live paycheck to paycheck and
you save you hold no investment and you
simply put your money in dollars
you will be worse off in the future than
you are today
if you spend less than you make and you
take
some of the money and you put it into
investments i don't care where you
invest it
and you hold it for long periods of time
and you're a halfway
intelligent person in terms of where you
put that money you will be better off in
the future than you are today
because the u.s dollar is guaranteed to
lose value
the devaluation of the dollar is done
in a way systematically it is not a bug
of the system it is a feature
it is done in a way that will either
punish you
or reward you and you have to know one
simple fact is get out of dollars
that is the whole secret you should have
enough money so that you have some sort
of rainy day fund
three to six months of expenses and then
you have to invest the only way to
protect your wealth
in the u.s economy today is you have to
invest
and so when you start to look at well
what are the other problems contributing
to this
we're going to pull up a chart here in a
second that shows the actual
minimum wage in america and what you're
going to find
is that minimum wage was higher
in 1968 than it is today
and so when you start to look at this
well you do this chart here first
the minimum wage in america is seven
dollars and 25 cents
this minimum wage in unadjusted terms
meaning not accounting for inflation
looks that it's like the highest it's
ever been
in 2009 we went to a 7.25
million dollar minimum wage it looks
like it's higher than it's ever been
but in terms of inflated dollars it is
actually
lower than it was in the 60s 70s
and 80s so what does that mean it means
that it from 2009
to 2021 anyone on minimum wage has been
paid the exact same amount 7.25 cents an
hour
but even though the dollar has been
completely destroyed during that decade
they're still paid 7.25 they make less
money today
than they made a decade ago on top of
that
we've got another chart that actually
shows 1968
and we're going to show exactly what has
happened since that time
where it was the highest minimum wage in
inflation-adjusted dollars
now the whole key to this is
understanding that your salary is not
going to make you rich when you look at
this
here's the real value of minimum wage
you can see in february of 1968
the inflation adjusted minimum wage was
10.54 cents
today in 2019 uh term dollars that's the
latest chart that we could find
seven dollars and 25 cents in july of
2009
seven dollars and 25 cents would be the
equivalent of eight dollars and seventy
cents today
right so literally people who get paid a
minimum wage
of 7.25 make less money today than they
did a decade ago
for a decade they've been paid less and
less money now there are a lot of
companies
and states that say you know what we
should pay people more than
and 25 cents what you find is there's
plenty of companies we have a whole list
of them
of all these companies that pay let's
say 15 an hour chipotle target best buy
amazon facebook google et cetera bank of
america pays 20
an hour costco 16 an hour right
but they do not adjust this on a
year-to-year basis
so in the last 12 months even though
we've printed 20
or more of all dollars in circulation
there has been no adjustment
to the minimum wage and so people are
getting paid less today than they were
even a year ago
this is the cause of wealth inequality
in our country
is that people literally year after year
after year get paid less and less money
now what does that mean in terms of the
cost of goods
when you start to look at the inflation
change from may 2020
to may 2021 food on average
up 2.2 percent in one year 2.2 percent
used cars and trucks are up 29.7
car insurance is up almost 17
close and apparel up 5.6
and airfare is up 25 now things like
airfare are not up because of inflation
25
they're up because there was a massive
drop in demand because of the pandemic
and now that people are returning
they're kind of normalizing some of it
but things like food are absolutely up
because of inflation
and so what we have to remember about
inflation is that inflation is not
experienced equally across a society
the richest people in the world not only
benefit
from inflation they got so damn
rich over the last 12 months because
they had investments the investments all
went up
bitcoin went up stocks went up
commodities went up everything went up
they love inflation why do rich people
love inflation because they're not
holding the currency
they're holding assets that are
denominated in the currency
and so rich people love inflation
because it makes them richer the rich
get richer and the poor get poor
but the bottom 20 to 40 percent of
people in an economy
majority of their spending is in
inflationary goods
food gas housing that makes up
majority of the money they spend on a
month-to-month basis
and those have been skyrocketing and so
they
feel inflation the most and so what's
happened over the last 12 months
is that the most vulnerable people
financially in our society
have been punished they've been punished
because they go to work every day they
work their asses off
they get paid the same amount regardless
of what's happening in the macro economy
they get paid an hourly wage
and then they go home and they try their
best to get out of debt
spend less than they make and simply
save for a rainy day so that they can
continue to build what everybody in the
world wants
which is simply a better life for them
and their family but because
the government and places like the
federal reserve have decided that they
are going to
absolutely manipulate markets because
god forbid the stock market went down
god forbid bad businesses went out of
business they've decided that they are
going to
change the way that the money is valued
by devaluing at a historic pace those
people who sit at home
they got hurt and so the entire point
of what we're going to do here is we're
going to walk through things that are
happening
in the business world and the investing
world and the economy and we're going to
teach people
what school won't teach them we're going
to teach them what the rich people know
but those rich people refuse to teach
anyone else because i personally believe
that education is a great equalizer
if we can simply educate people and give
them the same knowledge
that rich people have anyone in the
united states can become a millionaire
when i say anyone in the united states
can become a millionaire people get real
real uncomfortable people say that's
baloney
there's no way that that can happen but
here's some statistics for you
eighty percent of millionaires in the
united states
inherited zero dollars nobody gave them
anything they are self-made millionaires
from an inheritance standpoint 80
percent
four out of five millionaires got
nothing and they built it 33 percent
of millionaires in the united states
never made
as a household income them or them and
their spouse
never made more than 100k in a single
year
it's not easy it's hard but if you're
educated and you start early enough
anyone in the united states can become a
millionaire
and that's what rich people understand
and other people don't
is you have to learn to invest saving is
no longer a path
to wealth and freedom all right joe and
john what stats
or information do you have for us well
so
we can talk about inflation forever
right but i think that uh you brought up
two very good points that i always look
at and one when i started to really look
at inflation and what it does and why
it's important
was the idea of older generations right
you're told to go get a good job get
something with benefits
and start to save as much as you can and
earn your way out of that hole right and
start to maybe eventually reach that
million two million dollar net worth and
you're able to buy nice things and
protect your family and all this stuff
right
but i think when it comes to inflation
the thing that really turned it for me
was realizing that every single year you
have to get a two percent raise right
just to beat out inflation this year
it's five percent right
and that division and whatever and to
some degree it's healthy sure
five percent not as much but also the
concept of it not equaling everyone the
same right so impacting everyone the
same
so billionaires right uh a good example
is like steve ballmer people are
complaining he got when the pandemic
started he
uh he's the largest individual
shareholder of microsoft behind bill
gates i believe
and he had a 50 billion net worth before
he before the pandemic now he's at 100
right so
he had investable assets the stock did
really really well it's up over 50 or 60
his network doubled during the pandemic
so really well but his
the percentage of money he spends on
food and
used cars that are up 30 and insurance
that's up 17
and all these assets or all these
purchases that normal people have a
larger percentage of
is so small compared to the average
worker right so
i think in the us the percentage is yeah
44 of american workers are considered
low wage workers right so they're not
getting
a raise every single year right compared
to someone who owns a business and their
income fluctuates or they get larger
raises or larger bonuses and stuff like
that
so their ability to beat inflation
through higher wages is higher but when
it comes to low-income workers or
low-wage workers which the u.s has 50
percent of the population is
it's a lot more difficult to get that
right so you start to see hey look if
i'm not getting a two percent raise
every single year i'm losing money and
the way out of that is with investments
right so
uh you have savings accounts which offer
low interest rates right now but you
have stocks crypto bonds real estate et
cetera there's a bunch of different
assets
but the key is to measure your risk
tolerance against it and just look at
investments on a scale and get invested
the craziest part about all of this is
that nobody teaches anyone this in
school
that to me is the wildest part of
everything is that inflation
people just say oh it's about two
percent a year even if it was which it
is not
but even if it was only two percent a
year that still would be
drastic cause to teach every single
person
to go invest because that means if you
put a hundred
dollars into a bank account that hundred
dollars
a year later if we only have two percent
inflation
would be about the equivalent of 98 from
the year before
it still says 100 in your account but it
would be able to purchase
about the same as 98 the year before and
then a year after that
it continues to go down and down and
down and down and pretty soon
if you leave the money there for a long
enough period of time it becomes really
really
material but the key is that's if
there's only two percent inflation
the inflation that was measured the
consumer price index
in may of 2021 jumped five percent
five percent and that's the official
number because here's the things that
they do
they constantly change the way that they
calculate it they constantly say oh
here's the inflation number minus food
and gas right
there's all sorts of manipulation in the
way that they calculate these numbers
but they still said the official
number's five percent
my guess is that the unofficial numbers
or in reality
if you include everything most people
are experiencing close to 10 percent
inflation
over the last 12 months 10 in a single
12 months they printed trillions of
dollars
and told us not to worry but
rich people aren't worried rich people
cheered them on that's why you've seen
the mainstream media
that's why you see all of these folks on
wall street that's why they're not
complaining because they got richer
airline companies are the best example
there are some really really badly run
airlines
and those airlines got in a situation
last year
that was an unforeseen event nobody saw
a global pandemic coming
and their demand dropping drastically
but it happened
and rather than allowing those
organizations
to go into bankruptcy protection which
is there to protect
them and allowing for a
re-capitalization of the business
the airlines ran to the government and
they begged for money
the capitalist on wall street proved to
be socialist
they wanted a bailout from the
government and here's the funniest part
you know why they ran to the government
because the government gave them a deal
that no investor in their right mind
would have ever given them
because the government said we're going
to give you billions of dollars and
two-thirds of the money on average
you don't have to give back to us we own
none of your business
and you pay no interest to us it's free
money
that's what the government did they gave
billions of dollars to the airlines and
they said it's free cash
keep it thanks pick up the check next
time
right what investor would ever give a
company billions of dollars and not say
i own a piece of your business
or you got to give me back the money or
you got to give me back the money plus
interest
the airlines ran to the government
because they knew that the government
was the dummy in the room the government
was willing to give them a
sweetheart deal that nobody else in the
private market or in the free market
would give them
and so we saw that over and over and
over again
but at the same time all that was
happening there was millions of people
who filed for unemployment every single
day right
and this is where we start getting into
all kinds of issues
now when we start to understand what's
happening with inflation
let's chalk it up and say nobody
actually knows what the real number is
we don't know but what we do know is
that savings
is not going to be very helpful you have
to learn to invest
and so when you start looking at
investable assets things like
bitcoin or collectibles or things that
most folks would consider
the riskiest part of their portfolio
have exploded upwards
trading cards etc hundreds of percent of
appreciation
and when people see that they start to
say oh wow the markets have become
completely unhinged right i can't
believe that folks are
so reckless with their money they're
investing in all this crazy stuff
but even if you bring that closer and
you say well what's the most
conservative things you could do
maybe i just want to buy the s p 500
index fund
and simply dollar cost average into it
that's up
37 over the last 12 months
37 that includes the largest businesses
that got absolutely hammered by covet
literally millions of people got laid
off factories shut down manufacturing
facilities shut down supply chains
completely disrupted
all of these issues but the s p 500 is
up 37
over the last 12 months in this
situation
what we are learning is a common phrase
in the finance world of don't fight the
fed
if the federal reserve's gonna step in
they're gonna manipulate interest rates
down they're going to pump all this
liquidity in the market
simply get long and chill that's it
what asset class you need for your
portfolio
that's up to you but in today's economy
if you take dollars after you have
gotten out of debt and you've built a
rainy day fund
and you invested in assets
that aren't crazy crazy things super
conservative assets
and you simply chill jerome powell janet
yellen
politicians and the rest of the entire
economic machine
will make you richer than you've ever
dreamed of and it's because they're
manipulating the market
they're enriching themselves and you
just want to be along for the ride
that's how it works that is the entire
secret that they will not teach you in
school
is that in today's world you have the
ability to do what the rich people do
hold investments whether it's real
estate whether it is commodities
stocks crypto whatever you have the
opportunity
now when we start talking about housing
there's a whole other dynamic at play
here
the housing market has exploded upwards
the average price of a
of a residential home in america has
absolutely taken off like a rocket ship
now the reason is twofold one they're
manipulating the market and that they
had two emergency rate cuts in 2020 to
bring the interest rates down
near zero meaning that they literally
said you know what we want to
incentivize people to borrow money to
invest or to spend it so we're gonna
make the capital as cheap as possible
come borrow money and you don't have to
pay us back
anything if very very little and people
did
and they took that and they started to
refinance their mortgages they started
to buy
new homes but at the same time we have a
housing shortage
in america right every single year
i believe the statistic is that there is
a difference of how many people are
looking for homes versus how many are
coming online that is equivalent
to all of the housing in the city of
miami
it's about 250 000 homes if i remember
correctly
right hundreds of thousands we are short
and so at the same time that there's a
housing shortage
at the same time that they flooded the
market with cheap capital
and then said to everyone hey we're
going to have everyone move around a
bunch because now you're
wondering why am i living in a shoe box
in san francisco or new york and maybe i
actually want to go somewhere else
and so i'm actually going to go looking
to buy a home and that's where you get
this almost
squeeze of prices upwards again
if you only have cash houses in america
have almost become impossible to reach
if you simply live paycheck to paycheck
and you save
you will not be able to afford a home in
america which is pretty crazy to think
about
because we think of america as this
super financially stable place
and so that's the big kind of key to
this whole thing and you're going to see
us talk about this day after day after
day
so you have to understand inflation you
have to understand where to put your
money and you have to understand
what to do from an investment standpoint
all right let's talk about something a
little bit more fun
yesterday was the euro cup i'm lucky
enough to have a brother who's literally
an
expert in sports uh tell us about the
euro cup we're gonna break down the
financials behind this for people to
understand
a little bit what happened there and
then we're gonna talk about taxes and
what sports owners do
with that tax situation yeah so we we
went to the bar yesterday to start this
off and we went uh
to watch the second half and kind of
overtime and stuff like that and extra
time
uh at an italian bar the the stream went
out during the
during the game so people were yelling
some guy held his phone up it was
hilarious but
uh moral of the story was that england
lost
italy won uh and italy's gonna take home
over 30 million euros as a result so
this tournament has really evolved over
time it used to have eight
uh teams competing each year then it
went to 16. now it's at
and the prize money went along with it
so i have the stats here in 1992
uh the tournament in sweden there was 28
million euros distributed throughout the
teams
this year across europe there was 371
million euros distributed
so each team it varies but uh the winner
gets 10 million euros for winning the
actual game and then they get prizes
along the way for winning various
competit
uh contests throughout it and then you
get nine a little over nine million
euros just for competing
so the euro is a a cool tournament and
it's super
interesting to look back about how much
it has grown over time but i think
another interesting things when it comes
to sports is like
why do rich people buy sports teams
right and euro isn't probably the
perfect example because it's countries
and not individuals
but when you look at the us sports
leagues when it's the nfl mlb mba etc
there's a bunch of reasons right so one
of them is uh
long history of value appreciation right
so the average professional sports team
across all the
leagues i just mentioned premier league
included is up over 500
over the last decade so they've
increased dramatically in value
and then you look at it as a diversified
asset right so a lot of these people are
heavily invested in the stock market
they own businesses and et cetera
and they invest in this as something
that gives them exposure to a different
asset class that moves in a different
direction than typical stocks
so not only does it outperform the s p
500 over that time period but it's
diversified right
and then thirdly there's a bunch of good
tailwinds so when you look at meteorites
traditionally media rights have been in
broadcasting rights are what drive these
valuations much higher
uh there's a bunch of new digital
bidders coming in so amazon prime hulu
espn plus et cetera those rights are
going to drive higher as you have the
traditional bidders also competing for
those rights
uh there's sports betting in the u.s i
think it's macquarie said that 96
percent of u.s consumers
will have access to mobile sports
betting by 2025.
so huge acceleration in that pace and
then thirdly
uh there was a good article from pro
publica the other day about rich owners
and their ability to use it as a tax
use pro sports teams uh as an
advantageous uh example of taxes right
so
i think the example they gave was steve
ballmer uh and
i have the numbers here from the article
but essentially steve ballmer
was uh what they said was are you
looking at the stats
of bomber paid versus the concession
stance yeah
yeah john what was the stats do you have
it yeah i got it right here
um so there's accession stand worker uh
for the clippers
and she made including working at uber
so she doesn't even get paid enough to
live
based off what she does at the
concession she made forty four thousand
forty five thousand dollars in a year
she paid fourteen point one percent
in her federal income tax lebron
who plays in the nba and makes a lot of
money it makes a lot of money these are
2018 numbers too i want to be clear
uh lebron made 124 million and he paid
a rate of 35.9 so 36 percent of income
tax all right so we have a uh the
concession stand worker makes 45
000 paid 14 percent we have lebron who
made
would you say 100 million 124 and paid
35 percent yeah all right what's balmer
palmer made 656 million that year and
paid a federal income tax at 12 percent
so less than the concession yeah now to
be clear
percentages versus aggregate amount
steve baumer paid 75 million dollars or
so
in taxes in was it 2018 yep but from a
uh percentage standpoint he paid 12
versus the concession stand worker who
paid 14 he made more than 15
000 times more than the concession
worker and on percentage basis paid less
okay now here's an important part and
this is why we wanted to talk about this
right
one of the key things that we're gonna
consistently
say over and over and over again you can
spend your time
complaining and yelling and screaming
about
rich people make too much money rich
people get tax benefits rich people do
this
or you can take the time to realize that
the same rules are afforded to you
you can educate yourself on what the
rules are you can take the time to
actually
uh figure out from your current position
how do you start to do what rich people
do if you want to be financially free
go figure out what the financially free
do and then repeat the same thing
now what steve ballmer is doing here is
he's using
a company that he owns which is the team
and he's using the tax code
in a way that provides him certain
incentives
for investing and putting his capital at
risk
whereas if you are the concession stand
worker you
don't get that unless you own a company
or you own some type of asset so joe
maybe
break down exactly what steve ballmer is
doing here in terms of being able to get
a lower percentage tax rate even though
he still paid 75 million dollars in
taxes in 2018
explain how he's actually getting down
to that 12 tax rate yeah so he bought
the team for two billion dollars a
couple years ago
and last year the numbers pro publica
put out was he used he recorded
700 million dollars in losses for tax
purposes and the reason he's able to do
that
is when you buy a business right there's
you're purchasing assets really which is
buildings equipment
patents it could be anything right they
name a whole host of things that you can
depreciate over time as they lose value
but when it comes to sports those same
things are tv media deals player
contracts
everything that goes along with the team
which are much harder to determine as
depreciating assets because they renew
over time
but when you think about sports teams
they're scarce right there's closed end
structures so uh
you know there's only 30 or 32 teams
depending on the league and stuff like
that so there's no
ability for someone to come in and take
those broadcasting rights and those fees
and then you set a really low floor
right so you know i mean you set a good
floor you know
how much broadcasting rights are going
to be every year it's not
uh you're able to determine basically
how much you're going to make each year
beforehand
so balmer is essentially just taking the
losses against it
and using them against his income
personally right so he claims 700
million
that reduces his tax bill over time and
lowers his overall rate
now you can do this not just if you own
a sports team right i think part of what
people have to start to understand here
is
you can do with a sports team you can do
with a regular business you can do it
with real estate etc
but unless you get educated about it
these things are not afforded to you
and i think part of what we've started
to understand the more that we've looked
at a lot of these statistics
is that folks get really upset when they
see something like steve ballmer pay 12
taxes but the problem is that we have to
educate folks
on what they can do as well so if you're
an investor in the market there's
something called tax loss harvesting
this is not exactly what steve ballmer
did
but pretty much every wealthy person
does tax loss harvesting
tax loss harvesting is simply the idea
that if i
buy an asset and the asset goes down in
value
at some point during the year i can sell
the asset
and then reap the loss i can basically
take a loss
intentionally in order to then put that
against income
so let's say i made a hundred dollars in
a year and i took another hundred
dollars i was already in my bank account
i bought a stock the stock went down
fifty percent
i now have a fifty dollar loss that's
unrealized i haven't sold the stock yet
but i now decide that i'm going to sell
the stock at a 50
loss i sell it i have 50 and then i have
a 50
realized loss that at the end of the
year i'm going to take that 50
realized loss and i'm going to put it
against my income
now there's all kinds of nuance here
right and every single person's
situation is different depending on the
type of loss it is you may not be able
to count all of it for this year you
might have to roll it forward into
four years you may not be able to sell
let's say a stock
and then buy back that same stock
immediately so what the rich people will
do is they'll actually
sell one stock that's down they'll get
the realized loss
they'll buy a different stock that has a
very high correlation to the original
stock
they'll hold that for 90 to 100 days and
then they'll buy back into the original
stock
there's all kinds of things that you can
do around tax loss harvesting
but this is a specific strategy for the
wealthy
because they understand that the
greatest
hurt to your financial situation comes
from taxes
if you pay 20 30 40 50 of your taxes
of your income to taxes then that's
money you don't have to put into
investments in order to compound right
one of the things that wealthy people
end up being really really interested in
is they want to spend their money on
investments because they know that a
dollar today's gonna be worth more in
the future
if you are saving a dollar a day's gonna
be worth less in the future so you're
more incentivized to go buy things right
go buy things you don't need
so one of the things that absolutely
cracks me up is when we have these
conversations
uh if you take somebody like balmer
balmer also
majority of that 600 plus million
dollars is not income
most likely right in terms of he's not
getting paid 600 million dollars in
straight cash
from a job from an employer so it's
booked as income a lot of it is also
being booked as capital gains rather
than personal income
and so when you start to get into this
world of capital gains versus income
you realize that the tax rates are way
way lower if i have a hundred dollars of
income
and i pay fifty dollars of taxes that
means i have a fifty percent tax rate
right i have fifty dollars left over
if i was able to in an egregious example
completely remove
all of the taxes right i paid zero in
taxes yes i would keep all hundred
dollars
but that would be a doubling of my
take-home income in the first example
where i paid 50
taxes my hundred dollars i got to take
home 50. in the second example if i pay
zero i
doubled my take-home income because my
50 is now
worth a hundred and so what you start to
see is
even if you were able to cut the tax
rate from 50
to 25 now you were able to
increase your income by 50 that 50
now you take home 75. and so you've got
to get educated about how this stuff
works
because the wealthy are doing it and so
that is the whole key behind the
actual um behind the actual uh
issue that people are pointing out here
all right let's talk a little bit about
the actual euro cup itself in terms of
what what do you think about italy
winning like
england had to be destroyed last night
yeah there were some wild videos going i
mean
if we if we just forget about the
finance part of this for a second
the english soccer fans or football fans
they're nuts
i saw videos online yesterday that
literally made me kind of want to go to
england
for a football match next time because
they were just out of their minds
do we have a guess as to how much beer
they drank yesterday yeah they said
uh i have this oh you actually have the
staff yeah i have that
what is the statistic as to how much
beer was drank in england yesterday
13 million pints we're drinking and
that's a thousand pints a second
hold on 13 million pints of beer were
drank yesterday in england
yeah and that's a thousand pints per
second
yeah do we know how many bars there are
no probably not but
hundreds well you also got to remember
they're still at 60 restrictions due to
covid right so the bars were packed
we read earlier it was like five or six
or seven hundred dollars to basically
get a table at a bar to even see
the game then everyone else was outside
you know drinking the stadium was packed
obviously
it was wild atmosphere i i saw a couple
of videos
that i literally was like i can't
believe that
uh people put this on the internet and
how to remind myself oh they're drunk i
was just gonna say
stuff you couldn't even really put on
the internet i was like this is wild
all right and then what what is the
whole thing is like so now that italy
wins does
um uh england get like uh a second place
money or anything like that or does
everything go to the winner
no so they get you get money prize money
throughout the tournament uh england
gets 7 million euros for losing italy
got 10 million for winning and then
there's like group stage
prizes for winning each game you get
money just for qualify for the
tournament because not all the countries
qualify right so
there's prizes throughout uh in total i
think it was 370 million euros were
given out to all of the countries
and italy if you add it all up probably
took home a little over 30.
got it all right we're going to talk
about virgin galactic here in a second
but before we do that
if you're watching on youtube i need you
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel if you like the video more
people see it the more people that see
it the more people that get educated
like the video let's get 2 000 people in
here then if you're on
twitter make sure that you retweet this
reply like it
throw some fire emojis do whatever you
want i see people in the comments
asking where can you get this shirt this
shirt
is the day one shirt joe has on the
original the best business show shirt if
you go to thebestbusinessshow.com
you can order it we're only going to
sell the day one shirts through the
month of july
at the end of the month of july we will
never sell these again and the whole
purpose of these shirts
is everyone always claims on the
internet i i found them early
oh i saw that early on i was there since
day one
well i don't know if you were or not but
now we're gonna know you want to prove
that you were here day one
go buy a day one shirt there's shirts
there's crew neck hoodies
or i'm sorry cute crew necks sweatshirts
and hoodies
they've got the day one thing there only
sold through the month of july the
bestbusiness show.com
thebestbusinessshow.com
go get it stop asking me where you can
get it now you know all right
let's talk about virgin galactic uh
first we should just start with what
happened
richard branson yesterday uh was the
first
uh actually i don't even think he was
the first billionaire but he was the
first billionaire in recent time
to get launched into space now i got a
personal problem with this because this
isn't real
right this is not real space we're going
to get to that in a second but
virgin galactic and blue origin are in
this competition to see who can get
there first
richard branson was able to do it after
jeff bezos said he was going to go
we got to just call out richard
branson's a gangster for sending himself
to space right john
yeah bezos set a date and he's a
gangster just being like oh i'll just
pick a date before that
i'll just go nine days earlier so that's
the start
right is uh sending yourself is the
ultimate vote of confidence and so
virgin galactic publicly traded company
blue origin private company uh and the
whole idea here is they have two
separate types of uh kind of methods to
actually getting to what is called sub
or orbital space we'll talk about the
economics behind this in a second
but we've got this graphic that really
kind of highlights exactly how
they do it differently so blue origin
uses a reusable rocket with a capsule
and the entire idea is that there's
basically the crew
inside of the capsule and there's a
vertical takeoff if you will with that
with blue origin similar to what you
would see if you've ever watched like a
spacex
type uh launch virgin galactic on the
other hand they're doing some wild stuff
it looks like a plane
like they basically just fly this space
plane
and as they're flying the plane it
basically has four passengers two pilots
and kind of in mid-air the plane
essentially
drops uh the spaceship out of it and
then that kind of takes off into
suborbital space
now the reason why i say this isn't real
space is two things one
jeff bezos and uh richard branson
they're not astronauts there's no
claiming that they're astronauts now
right
they didn't go to the iss or kind of
true
space what they did do though was they
went to zero gravity
and so they were able to kind of hang
out in that sub-orbital uh
uh type atmosphere for a couple of
minutes
but to me this was just one of those
moments where we look at it and we say
damn it is so cool what can happen
when you put ambitious people who can
think critically from first principles
and want to solve
problems and they can literally figure
out how to launch themselves
into this uh kind of sub-orbital space
20
years ago this would have been nuts
there have been no way anyone would have
thought this was possible
but just to see somebody actually have a
dream of doing it
and then accomplish it is a huge
bullish trend and i think that it's just
further proof
we should be encouraging as many
entrepreneurs
capitalists innovators etc as we
possibly can in our society
because they solve problems they figure
things out and yes
i hope they make a gazillion dollars i
hope richard branson
makes 20 billion dollars off virgin
galactic why
because he's gonna solve the problem
look at this man this dude is not young
he's here floating around with no uh
gravity
inside of this thing he's having a blast
if you were rich
you could go and you could spend your
money doing all kinds of dumb stuff or
you could go and you could push the
uh kind of humanity forward and you may
argue over how important this was
but this is just a cool photo and joe
and john and i were talking yesterday
people that are mad about this
don't understand the importance of
having continued investment
having kind of the story behind how many
young kids yesterday
were able to say you know what i think i
want to go to space
i want to build this stuff in the future
and to me that's the most important part
yeah you're talking about him making a
billion dollars he's already collected
120 million dollars from
potential customers right so he's
already had 600 people sign up
and he initially had the sign up at 200k
and then moved it up to 250k so i'm
using those numbers
because i want to use 200k versus 250.
um
but he's already collected 120 million
dollars for this venture and for to take
people to
so my favorite part of the whole thing
was blue origin was tweeting out and
they were they're basically talking [ __ ]
they're they're like your windows are
small we're going higher
we don't want i think they said we don't
want our astronauts to have an asteroid
blue origin said new shepherd was
designed to fly above the karma line for
booth i don't know the carmilla line is
62 miles
above earth right and they went what and
if he were 55
yeah he went around 55 and they said so
none of our astronauts have an asterisk
next to their name
[Laughter]
listen i don't i don't know where
exactly the the uh line for
astronaut or astronaut with a asteroid
to be clear the u.s
air force and the faa set the boundary
at 50 miles at 50.
96 percent oh yeah they said 96 of the
world
recognizes a hundred miles as as or 100
kilometers as
space got it and so how high did they go
yesterday
they didn't reach 100 but blue origin is
that's why they're saying they don't
want their astronauts to have an
asterisk
but do we call them astronauts i mean
the guys is jeff bezos an astronaut now
if i'm like once he goes he's calling
myself an astronaut
listen if i like in his tinder profile
i'm sure jeff bezos has called himself
an astrologer right
but in terms of him or branson like do
they call themselves an astronaut now
well it sounds like bezos can
listen richard branson is what 70 yeah
he's 70 years old he's worth 6 billion
bezos is what he's in his 50s i think
he's worth 200 plus billion dollars
and these guys are launching themselves
into space do we think net on a net
basis
billionaire space race uh including elon
musk
do we think that it's a net positive for
the world or we think that this is
actually bad and they should be spending
their money elsewhere
they can spend their money on whatever
the hell they want right like and i
think it's different virgin galactic is
essentially a space tourism company
right so they're doing it with the
with the idea of bringing other people
up there and billionaires and you
mentioned how many people have already
paid and how much they've already raised
for that
elon musk's venture is completely
different but in in reality like these
are the things these guys have always
dreamed about that's what branson was
saying he's like i've dreamed about this
like while i was a kid uh you know i'm a
billionaire it's one of the things i've
always wanted to do now i'm one of 500
people in the world to do this
so it's incredibly impressive that he's
put together two decades of this and
and he's obviously invested billions and
billions of dollars to do it and it's a
dream come true for him so i think
that's awesome i don't have any uh
complaints about what he does with his
money
but i think they're all approaching it
from a different angle right so bezos is
doing something else with uh with blue
origin he's doing something else with
virgin galactic and musk is doing
something else also
i think it's also it's bringing a lot of
eyes on the space right so a lot of the
regulations and stuff that are in place
today have been in place for
years some even dating back to like the
cold war era
and um one thing i thought that was cool
was people talk about the climate change
carbon emissions and everything like
that
uh branson said that flying unity is
equivalent to
a business class flight from london to
new york
it is the same carbon at like a mission
or the same impact
yeah i mean did you see the the uh story
where they had uh
i forget who was lecturing on all of the
esg stuff in sun valley like the
billionaire summer camp
and all those guys had flown there in
their private jets and then we're
getting a talk as to like hey we should
all reduce our carbon emissions
like it's a little weird to be uh to be
given that talk after everyone flew
there on their private jet
but i do think that there's uh there's a
trade-off right and to me what's so
fascinating about this is
these are some of the best entrepreneurs
like forget the space stuff for a second
right
you have elon musk jeff bezos and
richard branson all working their
butts off to try to get whatever the the
thing is they're trying to do with space
but these folks are not a rocket
scientist by training right they're
literally going after this from an
entrepreneurial mindset
and i think that one of my takeaways is
just like
richard branson had nothing to do with
hardware or
sciences or any of that stuff throughout
his kind of entrepreneurial career
but if you're a good entrepreneur and
you understand how to build businesses
you can apply those skills to all these
different industries
and you go hire the experts but you
still understand how to build a business
how to solve problems how to use capital
markets to your advantage
and now they've got fully functioning
businesses
that are launching themselves into space
right and to me what's interesting about
virgin galactic is going to be
if you have this technology can you do
other things with it right
i forget who was tweeting it but
somebody was tweeting saying that uh can
now all of a sudden we go from like
new york to singapore in 20 minutes
right or
in two hours so yeah i was going to say
that the one thing that surprised a lot
of people online was that
it seemed people were surprised by the
fact that it looked like a real plane it
didn't look like your typical spaceship
that you would see in a movie or what
bezos
and musk are building it looked like a
real plane so i'm assuming there's more
commercial applications for that
but i guess that's something to to be
determined down the line
all right we're going to talk about
crypto
bitcoin stable coins etc here in a
second but
peter shift is coming on the show peter
schiff is coming on
in uh about 20 minutes or so we're gonna
have him on
uh we're gonna do one more topic and
then when peter comes on he's gonna help
us explain a lot of the issues in the
current economy
i'm sure he's gonna shield gold uh we're
gonna tell him that he probably should
sell all of his gold and buy bitcoin
we'll get into all of that i wish that i
could get his son spencer to also
uh tune in and uh and debate with him
but i don't think that's gonna happen
uh so before we get to schiff we're now
gonna talk about
uh a story from last week where visa
crypto cards have racked up a billion
dollars in spending
and those the spending on these cards uh
most of this is debit cards right so
these are people who
historically have used a debit card
where
when you go to the store you swipe your
card it is debiting
your fiat bank account so if i got a
hundred dollars in a bank account
i go i select my card uh for 20 bucks
now i got 80 in the account and i pay
the merchant 20 bucks
and that card is the user experience in
which i i tend to do that
but as crypto bitcoin or other assets
start to become more and more a
percentage of people's
financial portfolio or their actual kind
of reserve currency
visa has realized maybe we should have a
card
that when you swipe it doesn't debit
your fiat account
it debits your crypto account and so
they've said that already in 2021 about
six months in
a billion dollars was spent and so when
you start to see that you start to say
to yourself
wait a minute 18 trillion dollars is
spent every year with cash in cards
and a billion dollars today uh in the
first six months about a two billion
dollar annualized run rate
was spent using these crypto cards
what's fascinating to me about this is
when you look at it from a kind of a
bullish standpoint for bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies
we're not asking people to change their
user experience in this specific example
right if you're used to going to the
store you pull out a physical
card and you swipe it now you're able to
use
the digital asset as a currency with the
same user experience you have to change
anything you don't have to
figure out qr codes or get an app on
your phone or do anything you can just
use this card
now the downside is the western world is
very very far behind the payment systems
of
the east and of the continent of africa
so a lot of people don't know this but
a couple years ago there was something
like an m-pesa or now there's a couple
of competitors as well
that said look most people in countries
uh on the continent of africa they don't
have bank accounts
and they're just now starting to get uh
some sort of smartphone penetration into
the countries
what if we create a payment system where
you're able to use your phone
to conduct everyday business send money
to friends
spend it at the store et cetera and so
there's a very strong argument that
countries in africa have drastically
leapfrogged the infrastructure in the
united states
because they've gone mobile first it's
all mobile first banking
and again it comes down to entrepreneurs
innovators
and problem solvers saw a real problem
they were able to build technology and
they were able to make the world
better for those people they were able
to open up financial services and access
to
digital payments for an entire continent
of people or at least the countries that
they're in on the continent
now the united states is trying things
like apple pay google pay etc
they're trying to get there with some of
the digital payments but majority
of americans still use cash or cars
right physical
kind of plastic cars or the actual cash
now
in the east uh places like china or
other places in asia
they've gone almost fully digital as
well so they have qr code systems
they've got these like octopus cars that
you can use
in terms of using on the subway and all
these different systems
what we are heading towards is a fully
digital financial system
which will not include physical cash or
physical cards it will all be digital
in the future what's fascinating to me
is when we look at
visa visa is faced with the classic
innovators dilemma
they have the option to continue to
build their business in kind of the
legacy financial system with fiat
currencies with the current banking
partners that they have
and if they wanted to they could
completely shutter that business shut it
all down and say hey
crypto is the future bitcoin is the
future let me go into that market
but they're not doing that they're
actually very very uniquely
figuring out a way to continue to serve
the existing customers while almost
building out an entire crypto division
there's a guy kai
sheffield at visa who's the head of
crypto he's building out this entire
division
uh to almost disrupt themselves right if
this is going to be the future let's
make sure we are at the forefront and so
they've done things with usdc and circle
and kind of stable coins
they've done partnerships with coinbase
and blockfi and i think gemini and a few
others
uh in terms of creating these cards uh
and then now they're also getting it to
other types of
payments or nfts etc what's fascinating
to me about visa
is visa is the leader in infrastructure
in kind of the traditional world if
they're able to
kind of adopt and get ahead of this they
will be one of the incumbents that is
not disrupted
but as we know from the innovator's
dilemma if you take all the payment
companies
and you put them kind of in align with
each other some of them will
uh uh kind of adapt to this new thing
others will be completely be destroyed
and so from an investor's seat
understanding who
is seeing the tailwinds who is
understanding where
um kind of customer experience and
customer uh trends are headed
and getting ahead of it is really really
important so it's pretty impressive to
see what visa has done so far
now there's a new product that is coming
to the market
uh for bitcoin and crypto enthusiasts so
historically we just had you can use the
assets themselves
you can use things like coinbase or
bitpay
or uh strike etc in terms of actually
using
uh and paying for things right through
these consumer-facing applications
then the cards came and those cards a
billion dollars in spending
now blockfi just announced and has been
releasing
uh things like a credit card that pays
rewards
in bitcoin rather than cash backer
airline miles so again when you swipe
that credit you're
borrowing money from somebody else to
pay for that item
but when you get the incentive for doing
that
you can get it in bitcoin back rather
than cash back or airline miles now
speaking of credit cards the average
balance of an american credit card
is 6 dollars six thousand dollars
is the average balance that means fifty
percent of the balances are higher than
that
john what is the average interest rate
uh average interest rate is around like
16 17 percent
so 16 to 17 percent annual
interest on a 6 000 or higher
balance there is a debt problem in this
country
it's not so what we end up finding
is that things like these bitcoin
rewards credit cards etc
are going to end up actually providing
an incentive for people to get a
different thing rather than airline
miles you now can get bitcoin
right and so my expectation here is that
the impact on the bitcoin or the crypto
market is going to be
uh block five is releasing theirs gemini
has one coming out there's gonna be
plenty of other people who follow
these companies are now gonna become
persistent buyers in the market
meaning that every month when block
fight goes to pay out the bitcoin
rewards
they're gonna have to go into the market
and buy bitcoin to fund it
and when they do that that's a
persistent buying and so block five is
paying 1.5 percent
interest uh or one i'm sorry 1.5 percent
reward or
bitcoin back on every single purchase
you spend a hundred dollars you get a
dollar fifty of bitcoin
and as those numbers grow from a user
standpoint a transaction value
standpoint
these numbers are gonna become pretty
big as to what they're buying on a
monthly basis
then you start to get more and more
companies kind of entering the market
doing this
it's going to become material over time
it may take two or three years
but over time that is going to happen
there's nothing that bitcoiners or
crypto enthusiasts love more
than being able to earn the asset of
their choice
simply because they're spending money
that they were already gonna spend
and so when we look at something like
visa coming out and saying this billion
dollar number
in the first six months of the year it's
got to be a pretty good tailwind right
yeah i mean it's uh it's it's what 50
merchants
are working with 70 million merchants
with 50 crypto platforms so that's
certainly impressive right
and i think for me uh one of the things
when i was first getting into crypto and
i realized with a lot of other people
who were getting into it
was that there's just a knowledge gap
right like no early on what is crypto
how do i buy it how do i sell it can i
spend it can i earn interest on it right
there's a million different questions
and people who haven't been involved in
the asset class for a long time
these are typical questions they might
ask i think something like this reduces
friction right so it's just an easy way
for people to buy and sell it
and use it at merchants that they they
go to every day and stuff like that
and i think visa is massive obviously
right there's hundreds of millions of
cards outstanding of theirs
debit credit gift cards et cetera in the
us uh they're working with
70 million merchants so i think that
combination of the friction
and the availability of the supply is
super important and then when you start
adding on other layers like the credit
cards and all these other things it gets
super interesting
one of the things to me that uh that
goes uh very unspoken about this
is uh there has been a massive influx of
people into the market
over the last 12 months uh if you look
at
um the on-chain metrics uh will clemente
recently pulled from glasnow they have a
thing called
new uh entity creation on the blockchain
for bitcoin 50 000 new entities per day
now all-time high
wow right huge number yeah john for
those that don't know
is the youngest of uh the five pomp boys
and
uh the only one not wearing a business
show shirt yeah it's all right
hey they only sent us two as a test so
we're getting uh we're getting hit
if you buy one today you'll have one
before john
uh john john's 25 years old tel tell us
kind of uh
uh your perspective on bitcoin and
crypto in general in terms of all of
your friends and what they
uh talk about and what they say yeah a
lot of my friends they
want they're they're mainly into crypto
bitcoin stuff like that they're not
around the grayscale trust anything like
that
a lot of them use simple platforms to
buy it right so
robinhood and companies like that uh
none of them actually use
brokerage or i guess uh none of them use
like their own ledger
some of them use coinbase um and
companies like that
a lot of them own gold i don't know one
person that owns gold
not at my age group so in mid 20s
what would you say the general portfolio
breakdown is of most people
your age is it a majority in bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies
do they have stocks no gold it sounds
like like walk us through if you had to
just guess
what is most people at the age of 25
dude i had my barber the other day
talking about he's looking for the next
thing that's going 10x
i was like whatever whatever he tells
you tell me so i can check john
[Laughter]
john's told me this before and it
actually was a pretty crazy like
psychological thing is uh
most of your friends we're gonna start
having your friends just call in and
just give them hell uh but most of your
friends
when they go to invest today they
literally are looking for 10x or bust
right like there's no concept of let me
just buy the s p
500 index and just allow it to compound
at
eight percent a year for the next 20 or
30 years i think there is some concept
like that but a lot of them know they're
looking for the next 10x
they're looking for parabolic growth
right that's what they say um
i know i know kids in meme stocks and
look this is not financial advice but
me and a lot of my friends we all have
different portfolios right um
some but most of them have what bitcoin
tesla
gamestop amc all the stuff that you read
in the headlines that you read right
none of them
uh none of them i don't think have like
very long term investments uh maybe
their amc investment is a 20-year
investment i don't know um
but that's more generally my thinking is
more long-term than versus short-term
yeah what's so fascinating is uh i'm
going to tell a little bit here
one of the things that you guys are
going to find with this show is we're
not journalists right we don't want to
be journalists we don't think that that
game's real
we also don't think there's such a thing
as unbiased journalists everyone has a
bias
we're just going to tell you what our
bias is right so majority of my
portfolio
is bitcoin and early stage startups the
majority of joe's is what
bitcoin and what else some equity yeah i
own a little roku
you got you guys are going to find out
joe loaded up on roku and
it took off and he was talking all the
time we'll have to pull the graph
up one day and i'll circle where i
bought
so joe's got a bunch of roku stock plus
bitcoin and then john
is what mostly bitcoin and tesla bitcoin
i have some tesla some s
p um all right john john's a little bit
diverse
yeah john's a little bit more
diversified than the rest of us but uh
uh i think that the key thing here is
there's a very real psychological
impact to a lot of manipulation in the
market right there are a lot of kids
right now who literally think
that there is zero difference between
gambling on the nba finals game and
buying a stock today hoping it doubles
and then they sell it a week from now
literally someone just commented in the
youtube chat saying they're better off
using fanduel or draftkings
so like that's all you need to know
that's essentially the same thing
like when you start to think about that
psychological impact of young people
who by the way so we're clear
the stock market is a casino that is
what is happening
there may be professionals they may wear
suits and ties they may wear cologne
but they are gamblers that is what they
are doing they are risking money
based on probabilities of something
happening in the future
now some people go to uh vegas
and they count cards and that's the
probabilities that they're trying to
play at let's say the blackjack table
there are other people who go and they
do a bunch of research
on the revenue or they take pictures of
the walmart parking lot or they take
video with uh some sort of thermal
camera and try to understand where the
oil levels are right
but they're trying to get information so
that they can wager
and risk capital on a probabilistic
basis in order to get a
return to get more money in the future
than they have today it's all gambling
now once we put that on the table and
say that's okay that's not a bad thing
people get really upset when i say that
that's not a bad thing you just have to
call it what it is you're risking
capital you're
betting on the future movement of a
price and
there may be ways to do it in a very
risk mitigated way there's also ways to
do it in a super stupid way as well
and that to me is the psychological
impact of the manipulation of markets
is that in a bull market everyone thinks
they're a genius and these young kids
for the most part and john uh has
introduced me to some of his friends
who fit this build perfectly they
literally if i will talk to them and be
like hey what do you own
they'll tell me things that i'm like why
do you own that
and they'll say to me because there's no
way
it doesn't hit and have some price
target in their mind and so it's
fascinating to me so i ask them you know
why do you think it's gonna hit that
price target
and the reasoning behind it is usually
things like well my friends are buying
it
right or something like well so and so
talks about it all the time so i figure
like there's more people are going to
keep buying it
there's no analysis of the actual
underlying asset but
that is the concern when you start to
manipulate markets
is that you start to remove all risk
and when you remove all risk from a
market people start to do
things that are only focused on what
they can gain if you talk to the best
investors in the world they'll talk all
the time about what the risk is
they'll talk about trying to be as
resilient as possible they'll talk about
trying to avoid anything that could
potentially lose them money
but when you remove that risk when you
outlaw bear markets when you
ban market corrections and people can
literally just go
levered long like in the last 12 months
that's what young people are going to do
that is their introduction to the market
is they can just go long
by the way they've been right most of
the retail investors have outperformed
the hedge funds
over the last 12 months but it's because
they
understood that everything was just
going to go up they may not have
understood the macro environment they
may not have understood interest rates
they might not have understood
quantitative easing
all they knew is that every single stock
is going up every single stock is going
to continue to go up and so if i just
buy i'm going to have more money in the
future
now the problem obviously becomes if
that ever stops and that's the part i
think that
folks are trying to get their heads
around what did you put out on that
video when the pandemic started you said
just go long and chill and the
government's gonna make you rich rich
rich
yeah listen if you were in the stock
market if you just bought the s p
500 you put 100 you have 137 today 12
months later
and all you had to do was simply hit the
buy button
on your favorite app and chill
and they made you 37 returns the best
investors in the world the absolute best
in the world
if they can eclipse thirty percent a
year compounded
they're literally top one percent top
half percent uh
of all investors in the world 37 was
the industry benchmark the s p 500
there are stocks that exploded upwards
my brother joe roku
absolutely exploded right there's
fundamental analysis
what was the fundamental analysis on
roku we'll do a whole topic on that one
he did he's walked me through the
analysis it was actually pretty good i
was pretty impressed by it
but the point being that most people
just started buying things and the
market went up
it's a manipulated market if you take
the u.s stock market from 1971 to today
and you look at it denominated in
dollars you price all the assets in
dollars
it is a literal 45 degree line up into
the right
why because that's about the rate at
which the dollar has been devalued
right that's what we're seeing is the
dollar that the asset is denominated is
being devalued you're seeing the actual
assets just go up 45 degree angle up
into the right regardless of what's
happening in the world 45 degree up and
to the right
if you take that same stock market you
denominated in gold
it's down since 1971. so the underlying
asset is almost more important
than the actual asset you're buying
right the asset you're denominating it
the dollar is guaranteed to lose value
they're going to continue to devalue it
over a long period of time
we are going to come back in about three
to four minutes maybe five minutes
with peter schiff we're gonna spend a
second here we're gonna make sure we get
him
on to the show and when we come back
i'm gonna lay into peter schiff and i'm
gonna ask him what's wrong with the
economy but then i'm gonna try to
convince him to actually buy some
bitcoin
and if he agrees to buy even one bitcoin
the world will change see you in a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right bang bang we're back and we
got peter schiff with us
this is about to be fun my brothers have
never met peter before
so this is gonna be their first uh uh
interaction with peter i met his son
though
yeah they did meet his son spencer uh
when he was here in miami
uh peter's one of the smartest guys i
know about the economy
what's wrong with the economy uh what's
going well in the economy
and what people should do about it minus
we disagree on one specific thing which
is what is sound money
we'll get into that uh let's bring peter
up let's see if we can get him here
and uh peter what's going on man
peter can you hear us yeah i can hear
you
all right hear me awesome yeah you're a
little low they're gonna turn yeah i
mean i see that i'm in the shade here
like like i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm like
you know one of those guys speaking you
know you can't see my face because i'm
divulging
some secrets and i'm embarrassed about
it you know listen you got no secrets
all right let's jump right into this
thing
i try to see where if i can where i can
move the computer
if i put it in a little desk
ah there you go there you go you know
what so i gotta figure out where i can
put this
where i can put the computer all right
ah there you go
i gotta find something that i could set
the computer off just hold it just hold
it we're gonna go for 45 minutes
look there's a table over there by the
by the couch hold on
all right all right we'll wait we're not
live or anything
are you going to do construction right
now
i know i mean i'm in switzerland i'm in
a hotel
oh my god that's a nice ass hotel you
got going on there
well we're here for a month so all right
all right all right are we good now
hold on make sure you have pants on we
don't want you to have no i have pants
on or anything
no i got pants they're short pants
though but they're pants
all right you're here hold on you're
here you got uh
my two brothers uh joe and john who you
may be able to see here in a second or
not we'll see
uh let's start with what are the
problems in the economy
right you you have been one of the most
vocal voices in terms of the
manipulation of the markets and the
fed's actions
walk us through kind of your
understanding of what the hell is going
on
and what they're doing that uh you think
is a mistake
well i mean everything they're doing is
a mistake i mean there's a lot of
problems with the economy
and the reason the economy has so many
problems is because the government has
made so many mistakes
but what we're experiencing now is just
the consequences
of all the can kicking see whenever the
government creates a problem
they don't want to deal with the problem
because that's politically too dangerous
all they care about is kicking the can
down the road so that it's somebody
else's problem after the next election
well all we've done is catch up to the
can
you know every time we catch up to it
it's bigger there's bit there's more
problems than it had before
and so that's what we're experiencing
now in the economy because when covet
happened
we really gave the can a big big kick
because
covet really exposed a lot of the
problems in the economy
in in an even bigger way but again
rather than dealing with those problems
just like we failed to deal with them
after the housing bubble popped or we
failed to deal with them after the
dot-com bubble popped
uh we again made the same mistake which
is we printed more money
we lowered interest rates right we and
we gave everybody more money to spend
so they can buy more products that they
didn't make with money they didn't earn
all in order to keep this whole house of
cards from falling apart
but it is going to fall apart it is
impossible
for the government to do this
indefinitely because the amount of
money they have to print eventually uh
becomes fatal to the value of the dollar
so what do you think peter
what do you think what do you think
happens at the end right so
fast forward what however long it takes
whether it's two years or 200 years
what does the end look like and are
there historical examples that you point
to in terms of
this is likely to be what it actually
looks like when uh
uh when kind of the end happens or they
can't keep this up
well i mean it isn't going to happen in
200 years i mean if it takes 200 years
i'm wrong right i mean there's no way
it's going to last for 200.
there's no way it's going to last for
20. can it last for two
i suppose it could last for two uh
but it may not i mean it's it's
surprises me
that it's 2021 and we haven't had a
bigger crisis yet
in that we've been able to get away with
a lot more money printing and much
larger deficits
than peter schiff a decade ago uh you
know would have
uh imagined so like if we were doing
this interview in 2011
instead of 2021 and you told me how big
the national debt was going to be
how large the budget deficits would be
how much money we would be printing
uh you know i would have said yeah you
know we're going to have a crisis
you know before that could get that big
and so i would have been wrong about
that so
i think happens at the end though what
at the very end
what happens does the dollar lose global
reserve status
does it go into hyperinflation like what
do you think happens
well i mean first of all it depends on
how you define hyperinflation i mean are
you talking
you know ma weimar republic zimbabwe
you know stuff like that or you know
countries that have had high rates of
inflation but maybe not
you know like where they completely
destroyed uh the currency where you're
talking about you know trillions to buy
a cup of coffee
um you know we're gonna have very very
high inflation
uh at a minimum and i'm talking about
worse than the 1970s
that may not constitute hyperinflation
but it's going to be pretty bad
i do think that the dollars days as the
reserve currency are over
i kind of have a hard time imagining
a final scenario where the dollar
retains
reserve currency status so i do think
it's going to lose that status
you know where i'm not sure when the
date is i was i meant to look that up
but we're almost at 50 years
since we went off the gold standard in
1971
and the dollar should have been rejected
at that time
as the reserve currency because the only
reason it was the reserve currency
was because it was backed by gold and
you know a lot of people now try to say
that you know they're talking about the
debt ceiling and you know we can't
default on our debts and america has
never defaulted
that's not true 1971 was a default we
promised all of our creditors to repay
them in gold
for their federal reserve notes and for
their u.s treasuries
and then we defaulted and said we
promised to give you gold
and now we're going to give you nothing
and and so the dollar should have lost
its reserve status then
but it didn't the dollar got marked down
but it it didn't get you know counted
out it
it held on to that status so i think the
next move
is for the world to totally reject the
dollar
and and to go back uh to the monetary
uh system that existed before the dollar
which was gold as the primary reserve
rather than than u.s dollars hold on
hold on don't get into the gold stuff
yeah we got we're gonna do that in a
second
what do you think inflation is right now
so the main number for cpi was five
percent what do you think inflation is
are they right well first of all
inflation is the expansion of the money
supply that's the
actual definition and so money supply is
growing what 20
a year 30 a year it's really really big
now as far as
um what is the actual increase
in the cost of living the consumer
prices which is what
most people uh think about when you talk
about inflation
well the way the government measures it
using the cpi
if you annualize you know the first half
or the first five months of this year
i think we're running it about eight
percent a year increase in the cost of
living
but i don't think that accurately
reflects
what's really happening with prices
because i don't think the consumer price
index
really captures the true extent to which
prices are going up so
my guess would be that right now we have
annual inflation
probably between 10 and 15 right now
that's what americans
are experiencing as far as their cost of
living which certainly rivals or exceeds
the worst of the 1970s so we've already
got that
the thing is the fed and the government
is telling us and everybody is telling
us this
that it's all transitory that this is
all just related
to the reopening of the economy and so
we don't have to worry about it
but that's not why we have this the the
prices are going up
because of what the government did in
response to covet not because of covet
not because of the reopening it's
because of all the money printing
it's because of all the deficit spending
yes the fact that we're not producing
as much stuff is part of the problem a
lot of people aren't working and so they
didn't make stuff
but the problem is as we made less stuff
we printed more money
that was a huge mistake we should have
printed less money
the feds should have drained liquidity
as the economy contracted
not added it they just threw gasoline on
the fire
so deflation is going to get much much
worse uh what people
are experiencing now the only trans the
only the only way this is transitory
is that we're transitioning to much
higher inflation
all right so uh if we're now at 10 to 15
percent
what do you think is likely if they
continue on the path that they're on
they continue to print trillions they
continue to keep interest rates low
when you say much higher is that a 25 30
percent
50 percent like is there a way for you
to kind of identify what you actually
think we could get to in the near term
uh in terms of uh the continuation of
their policies
well look i mean we can continue with 15
to 20 percent
inflation for a number of years and if
you think about what that means that
means like the dow jones has to go up 15
20 just to stay even right
your house has to go up 15 to 20 percent
and
that's actually happening right now i
mean if you look at real estate prices
uh you know around the country i mean
they're really going up i mean
even more so in puerto rico it's more
like they're going up 15 20 percent a
month
uh but i mean all around the the country
you're seeing this
uh but it's also uh consumer good prices
uh that are going up i mean i get emails
all the time
people share with me the announcements
of price increases
that they're getting either from their
company where
it's their employer kind of letting all
the employees know
you know how much prices are going up or
they're just sending me their consumers
and they've gotten notices
from various companies that they buy
from letting them know what the price
increases are
and they're huge you know i've never
seen price increases this much
and it's not like we're just making up
what we lost during the pandemic
these are huge increases from where the
prices were before the pandemic started
so when you start thinking about um kind
of
what people can do with this right if
inflation's high
how do you think about where they can
actually put capital
uh in order to protect it is it
something where uh we all know that
you're into gold
is gold the only answer or are there
other types of assets that you think are
worth
folks looking into or or kind of doing
research on
well you know what inflation does is it
wipes out the value of paper assets
so if you have cash in the bank uh
inflation is bad if you own a bond
that's even worse because people are now
going to pay you
your money that you loan them but
they're going to pay it back in the
future
well if you have inflation money in the
future is worth even less than money in
the present
so the longer the duration of that bond
the more of your purchasing power you're
going to lose
by the time you get your money back so
you don't want to own bonds you don't
want to have
cash value in things like annuities
let's say you have an annuity
and it's going to pay you a fixed return
well that return is going to erode away
in purchasing power
as a result of inflation so you don't
want to fix annuity you don't want
cash value in an insurance policy what
inflation does
is it transfers purchasing power from
creditors to
debtors so you want to have debt that
will get wiped out
but you don't want to just go out and
borrow a bunch of money
and you know buy consumer goods because
you still have that debt you don't the
consumer goods are gone
you want to buy real assets that
generate income that can service the
debt
in the short run and that will
ultimately retire the debt in the long
run
as the debt is destroyed in value
relative to
uh you know the assets that you own so
you want to own real stuff in inflation
you want to own assets and so what i own
is i own a lot of stocks a lot of common
stocks
looking around the world at what you can
own you know whether it's real estate
or stocks or collectibles i think
that value-oriented stocks
dividend-paying
stocks in countries like where i am here
in switzerland i think there's still a
lot of value
in some of the swiss stock markets you
know other countries that i invest in
i think that relative to other assets
and i'm looking at property while i'm
here and i think residential real estate
is very expensive compared to what i can
buy publicly listed
companies for and the dividends that i'm
able to get so i think that
being an equity owner of a business in a
country
that is not nearly as screwed up as the
united states has much sounder
underlying economic fundamentals where i
can see real investment value
in the stocks meaning the p e's are not
too high the dividend yields are not too
low
you know well-managed companies been
around for a long time so i like owning
real stuff i don't want to buy the bonds
of these companies because inflation
will destroy their value i want to be
the equity
owners because the stockholders benefit
when the bonds are destroyed because
that transfers purchasing power
from the creditors to the equity
investors
but i also want to own gold as a
commodity
because what you're doing with inflation
is you want to preserve your purchasing
power so the price of everything that
i'm going to want to buy in the future
is going to go up
well the price of gold is also going to
go up because there are people who need
to buy gold
jewelers need to buy gold because they
got to make jewelry uh computer chip
manufacturers need to buy gold because
they need to conduct electricity their
chips
you know the dental industry the uh
aerodynamics you got all you know you
got a space race going on right now well
they need they need uh
gold to get up there there's a lot of
industries where they're going to be
buying gold in the future and it's going
to be more expensive
just like you know all everything else
so
i don't want to buy a bunch of oil
because i got no place to put it
i don't want to buy a bunch of wheat
because hey i mean wherever i got to put
that
it may not you know stay eventually it's
going to you know rot
and you know the shelf life of a lot of
the things that i might want to buy in
five or ten years i mean i can't buy it
now
but i can buy the gold now because i can
get a lot of value in a small place
and in five or ten years when i need to
buy that stuff
i can use my goal because i could trade
my goal for it
so it's a real commodity hold on though
so i got a couple of questions from a
portfolio standpoint
one what are the biggest stocks that you
and like in terms of allocation of
portfolio what are like the most popular
uh or the largest allocation you have to
individual stocks and then two how do
you think about
over the last 12 months gold's
essentially flat right it's kind of
plus or minus maybe 50 basis points on
any given day over the last few weeks
um is that a positive for gold or a
negative for gold given that they
printed trillions of dollars so what's
the largest allocation to
individual stocks and how do you think
about gold's performance in light of all
the printing
well is that most of my personal
portfolio
is in individual common stocks my
largest allocation
personally to a sector is mining
precious metals mining
and that's because of how bullish i am
on gold but i also have a big wading to
energy
and other uh natural resources you know
basic materials
we own a lot of real estate trusts some
of those stocks really got beaten up
after the pandemic
uh there's a lot of value there we own a
lot of telecom there's a lot of value in
those sectors
i own a lot of pharmaceuticals uh you
know a lot of different sectors and
companies
uh you know i have managed accounts
where i build portfolios for people
at europe civic asset management and you
know we have a professionally managed
portfolio
of individual foreign equities and
you've probably heard that everybody
has been chasing momentum and indexing
for a decade or so
it's the uh it's the value stocks the
dividend yielding stocks
uh that have kind of lagged during this
bubble so there is
investment value there not in any one
stock i mean we like to have a
diversified portfolio
of companies that work together you know
so but as far as gold is concerned
look gold in a short time span and you
know for some investors who day trade
a year may seem like an eternity but in
terms of goal the year is not very
long and you know so in a shorter run
like that
gold is going to simply reflect what
people believe
is going to happen to the dollar to
inflation to
interest rates at a particular point in
time
and i think the reason that we haven't
seen an
even bigger move up in the price of gold
and you have to remember
you know 20 years ago when we started
this decade gold was under 300
an ounce and now it's 1800 i mean gold
has actually beaten the s
p 500 so far during you know this
millennia
but the reason that we're not at 3 000
or four thousand
is because the vast majority of
investors
do not appreciate what's happening they
they see inflation picking up they are
underestimating how bad it's going to be
and at the moment they believe the fed
is going to be able to
prevent the inflation from becoming too
big a problem
even if it doesn't solve itself by being
transitory
the fed will raise interest rates it'll
taper its assets purchases and that'll
be enough
and the fed's going to save us from you
know a repeat of the 1970s or something
wrong worse
they're completely wrong inflation is
going to be much worse than anybody
thinks you know in the mainstream and
the fed's going to do nothing about it
even though inflation is going to be
worse than everybody thinks
not only is the fed not going to fight
it the fed is going to fuel the fire
the fed is actually going to get more
aggressive in its monetary easing
it's going to expand its qe program not
taper it
it's not raising interest rates despite
the fact that inflation is going up
and when investors finally wrap their
arms around that reality
they're going to bid the price of gold
through the roof all right so when we
start thinking about
financial markets in general we've been
talking all day about uh people who hold
no investable assets they've been
getting crushed
you know minimum wage hasn't gone up
since 2009 yet price of goods is up 125
if you look at things like uh the
financial markets it seems like
bear markets are banned you know market
corrections are outlawed the
government's going to step in
every time what would happen if they
didn't
are we so far down the road now that if
the government didn't step in and
actually
provide monetary stimulus in these
market corrections would there be a
complete unwinding of the system
or is it something where they don't want
to find out so they just kind of keep
stepping in but maybe that actually
wouldn't happen
well absolutely right again you know
it's like a drug addict
they don't want to stop using drugs
because they want to stay high
you know maybe maybe the reason you
started doing drugs is because you have
a big problem
and you didn't want to deal with the
problem so you decide to get high
so you wouldn't care about the problem
but while you were all drugged up the
problems got worse
the worst thing that could happen is the
drugs wear off and now you're confronted
by the reality of your situation
so in order to you know delay having to
deal with that you just keep taking more
and more drugs
the problem is you know you get addicted
to it you build up a tolerance
and there's some limit to how large you
can increase the dosage without an
overdose
and you die and and that's kind of where
we are i mean have we got to the point
where we overdose
on qe and money printing and all that
but certainly if the fed were to stop
and let interest rates rise to you know
where the free market would put them
uh the stock market would crash the
housing market would crash
the economy would implode banks would
fail much much worse than 08
and the u.s government would be forced
to default
i mean it would have to default on its
obligations to pay
benefits like social security and
medicare it would have to default on
uh government pensions on treasury bonds
i mean all of these
chickens would come home to roost so
they're not going to let that happen
right the politicians at the federal
reserve are going to do everything they
can
to keep blowing air into this bubble
until it explodes
so when that happens you know the dollar
you know implodes because
they can keep printing money as long as
the world keeps accepting it right they
can keep giving everybody money to spend
as long as the people that actually make
the stuff are willing to
exchange it for the money we print well
at some point
it does you know they won't want it
anymore and then you know the music
stops
right now interest rates are around zero
percent you said the free market kind of
interest rate where do you think that
would be is
that three percent one percent 10 no
no i mean much higher much much higher i
mean
interest rates are determined by supply
and demand
absent the intervention right so
if you think about the price right
interest rates or the price of money
so where are the supply and demand
dynamics there well the supply
is all the people who are saving money
so think of all the americans who are
putting money
in a bank right they're the savers so
they constitute the supply of savings
that could be loaned out what's the
demand well it's everybody who wants to
borrow
that savings so that would be
individuals
who want to buy homes who want to buy
cars who want to go to college
who want to buy stuff on their credit
card it would be corporations who want
to buy back stock or they want to invest
to buy some new equipment it would be
the u.s government
borrowing money to pay benefits or to
build infrastructure whatever it is so
you got everybody trying to borrow money
there's nobody saving it so you have all
this demand
you have minimal supply where's price
going to be
price is going to be very high all right
i want to talk hold on i want to talk
about social security you mentioned
social security
and to me this is one of the things that
people don't understand
so historically social security uh
people contributed to it
they then took that money they being the
government they took that money they
basically were able to generate
a kind of low risk return they used the
return uh to pay out benefits later on
and the whole idea was as more and more
people contributed they would continue
to take
the return that they received on those
investments from the government
and they would then pay that out as
benefits today we're an environment
though
where people are basically contributing
they haven't been able to keep up with
the rate of return that they need in
order to pay for the benefits
and so would you consider the social
security system a ponzi scheme at this
point
aren't they just taking new capital
inflow from contributors
to pay out the benefits and they don't
actually use the
return of the capital invested to pay
the benefits
well i mean it's been a ponzi scheme
since it was created
in fact you know my father wrote a book
on the social security swindle and he
in the i think the first page he said
that the social security office
should build a statue of ponzi like
right in front of the building
uh because that that's how uh the system
was devised i mean
the politicians of the day back in the
1930s
lied to the american public about the
nature of social security
they called it insurance you didn't pay
taxes you paid premiums
you received benefits so they tried to
you know market it as insurance which
was a fraud
but the way the system has always worked
from day one
is you have people who are paying in and
then you have people who are drawing out
and when it first started right you had
people who had paid in for a couple of
years
and then they drew benefits for 20 or 30
years based on all the people who are
paying in
the very first person who got a social
security check was a woman named like
i think was ima fuller or something like
that and she lived to be a hundred years
old and she made out like a bandit
she collected like 20 000 over her life
and she contributed like 10 bucks i
don't know what it was some tiny amount
of money
so she was a big winner because she came
into the ponzi scheme
real early but the thing is now you've
got all these people uh in the baby boom
that are stepping in their retirement
years and they're relying on
the generations that succeeded them to
pay in enough social security taxes
so that they can withdraw their benefits
there's no chance of that
in fact right now social security after
years
of collecting more than it paid
and loan and then using the rest to
basically buy government bonds and
subsidize a deficit
today because so many americans have
left the workforce
you don't even have enough americans
paying in now to cover the benefits that
are being paid
so there's already a deficit so the it's
like a chain letter that's already run
out of chain
and so uh the government is making up
the difference through this you know the
fed qe
uh but what's ultimately gonna happen to
uh the people on social security as i
said earlier
the social security benefits are gonna
be wiped out by inflation
the government's not going to default
and tell you you're not going to get
your benefits
they're going to pay you your benefits
with money that doesn't buy anything
and it's basically the same difference
so social security if you're expecting
to collect any social security
and you're you know my age even i'm 58 i
would just completely
assume that there's nothing there
because even if you get paid
the amount of money is going to be
trivial compared to what your cost of
living will be at the time that you
receive the benefits
all right i want to have some fun with
you you ready all right
i think i think i saw you tweeting
usually you you you
you're you're not you usually you're not
my type but all right
so i think i saw you tweet this that
you're pretty sure at this point just
given the assets you have and kind of
the rate of growth
you're going to be a billionaire in your
lifetime right yeah i'm pretty sure that
i will be i mean i mean i'm not one yet
but i'm
i'm i'm i'm reasonably close
like how close like a hundred million
close or like like
i'm closer than that but i'm you know
but i'm i'm i'm i'm
you know but i'm not a billion but i
mean within with with inflation
even without hyperinflation it's not
going to take much it's not going to
take much given what i think is going to
happen
because i'm earning more money so i'm
not not earning money and i'm investing
that money
in assets that i think you're going to
appreciate so i do think but you know
what
by the time i'm a billionaire there's
going to be a lot more millionaires so i
might
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna feel like a
billionaire yeah well here's the whole
thing is
uh a millionaire used to be really hard
to accomplish in the united states right
and that was kind of like the bar
everyone that was like the
american dream now billionaire i think
is kind of the the new thing you see it
in culture you see it in uh
kind of music all that kind of stuff
millions the new million right now who's
going to be the first trillion
trillionaire that's all i was going to
say the first trillionaire that's why i
say trillionaire energy
like who who's got the energy to be the
first trainer bezos probably got it
so basically what you're telling me is
that the stock market just goes a little
bit higher you're going to be a
billionaire
what do you mean no no well i'm not
invested in the u.s stock i got a few
u.s stocks
i got some you i got some energy stocks
in the u.s that's kind of really what i
would have to go to for you to be a
billionaire you know 2500
what gold yeah i know i don't know
i would guess if gold were at 5 000 i i
i that'd probably do it
well that's double just so we're clear
that that's pretty big because i
think i think for gold to get to 5 000
it should have already gone
i think it's going higher but i think if
gold goes to 5 000
which is what a triple call it that
yeah i think gold stocks will at least
10x
and so that alone would do it to me why
do you think the gold stock why do you
think the gold stocks the miners
are going to go up so much more because
they're uh cash flow and kind of uh
income producing and therefore people
will go and buy those
and kind of move those stocks more than
gold itself
yeah well you remember when you buy a
gold stock
you buy all the gold that they got in
the ground
at its reserves most of that gold you're
getting for nothing
because the analysts assume it's
worthless because it's too expensive to
mine it
but if the price of gold really goes up
much more than it costs to mine it all
of a sudden gold that was worthless
has a big value but i also think
that the value of gold stocks
will rise dramatically once the typical
portfolio manager
realizes that he needs to buy them i
mean right now nobody buys them
and so they you know they're trading
relatively cheap
i think at some point gold stocks are
going to enter a bubble i mean we're not
even really
in a true bull market yet let alone a
bubble
uh but i think eventually gold stocks
are going to get expensive
maybe i'll be smart enough to sell them
when when they do
but they're gonna get expensive but also
by the way satoshi nakamoto may be the
first trillionaire just so we're clear
satoshi's got a shot there i see people
assuming assuming he's alive or whatever
all right but
would you say the same thing is the
other thing that's going to help make
make me
that wealthy is if gold were to go up
that much
i'm assuming the dollar is also going
way down and i've got all these foreign
stocks that i own personally
and i manage you know right now i manage
i forget what it is maybe a billion and
a half or something like that
where i generate fees well if gold goes
to
5 000 i think i'm going to have 5 to ten
billion
under management maybe more so the value
of my business goes up a lot
right if i were to sell it or something
like that so
in that kind of world where gold is at
five thousand the dollar is falling
there's lots of inflation
a lot of people are sending money to me
to manage and therefore
you know my income is up the value of my
business goes up
also shift gold you know we're going to
be selling a lot more gold when gold's
at five thousand dollars an hour
you know it's going to be flying off the
the you know like off the shelves like
hotcakes
how many businesses do you have wait you
have euro pacific and you've got shift
gold those are the two main businesses
well i marky i sold
i you know i live in puerto rico now so
i kind of sold the businesses so i do
marketing for shift gold
i have euro-pacific asset management
which that's my main business i mean i
have a bank but and you have a bill
management is my and my mutual funds
right which is part of the asset
management company all right you got a
billion and a half in there right now
what do you charge on fees are you a two
and 20 guy
no because i don't i don't have a hedge
fund okay so i don't i don't i don't
charge people those those outrageous
fees so
i just charge a management fee sometimes
it's as high as two percent
for the smaller accounts but you know
but the big
boys get a discount the big boys get a
discount
yeah well as you get because the
economy's a scale but so
i usually charge between one to two
percent a year
and i bill quarterly to manage a
portfolio but
so it's not two and twenty it's maybe
one and zero or
or two and zero at the most so it's a
much better deal
than you would get from a hedge fund and
so what what i'm doing is really what a
global macro fund would do that's kind
of the approach that i take
but i don't charge anywhere near the
fees so you're making i'm my biggest
client you know so i mean
i'm doing the same thing with my own
money that i advise that people do
with their money they send me so that's
15 to 30 million a year you're like rich
rich
you're like you're like well i i you
know i got employees
i'm not i don't take it all you know i
got portfolio managers
you know i got sales reps so
you know i don't keep all of it but i
keep a good chunk of it yeah
you're in switzerland in a hotel that
looks like my house like i mean you're
well and because i live in puerto rico
right i pay a four percent
tax on the money i earn talk about taxes
that's what that's
wait that's when i get all this capital
gains my capital gains rate is zero
so talk about talk about taxes because i
know you're big on taxes you
got puerto rico residents you're doing
the whole thing explain to everyone
why you're so focused on taxes and
trying to
bring that tax rate as low as possible
so you can keep as much income as
possible
well i mean it's not what you make right
it's what you keep i mean that's we all
know that
and um you know it's an american's
patriotic duty
to minimize their taxes to pay the
lowest tax that they could legally pay
and that's not me that's the supreme
court said that so i'm
being a patriotic american and
personally i believe that any gov money
the government gets the government
wastes i think
money in my hands is is going to do
better than
money in the government hands and that
applies to every american keep the money
that you earn
but it's not just the income tax which i
think is so debilitating to the economy
it's the inflation tax we're talking
about inflation inflation is a tax if
you strip it of all the jargon
that's what it boils down to because
governments have two ways of taking
money from us
they can take it through taxes where
they take physically our money
or they can take our purchasing power
through inflation they just print money
and they spend that
but that means the value of our money
goes down because prices go up
and you know when joe biden campaigned
on not raising taxes
for anybody who uh earned less than four
hundred thousand
he's lying because the biggest tax
increases
are hitting the people who make less
than four hundred thousand because
that's where
inflation does the most damage it goes
to the people
who spend most of their money so if
you're spending most of your money and
most of the lower income people
spend everything that they earn well
they're hit hardest by the inflation tax
and they're getting clobbered right now
but the reason that i want to avoid the
inflation tax
is because as an investor inflation
can create phony capital gains so let's
say i'm right
gold goes to 5 000 10 000 i have gold
stocks
let's say i have you know even 50
million of gold stocks in that scenario
that turns into a billion dollars right
because the gold stocks go way up right
and now i sell and i cash out and the
government says oh you've got you know
this huge capital gains
well what if the same period of time my
cost of living has gone up five times
right so my gains are not really nearly
as big as
as the nominal numbers and it make it
even simpler
let's just say that you know my stocks
go
up 10 times but the cost of living goes
up 10 times
so the price of everything i buy is 10
times what it used to be
and my stocks go up 10 times i haven't
made any money i'm just even
if i sell my stocks i can still afford
to buy the same exact stuff
as i could buy before they 10x but then
if the government says oh you have a 50
capital gains tax now i'm i've lost half
my purchasing power
i didn't make any real capital gains i
had a phony capital gains
but the government was able to tax that
so by moving to puerto rico and this was
one of my primary motivating factors
they can never do that it doesn't matter
how high
prices go i don't have to pay a capital
gains tax because i'm locked at zero
and that doesn't apply to just me it's
all the people that have moved here
to take advantage of the same deal so
when you start to think about
bitcoin versus gold would you ever
consider i know you're not a fan of
bitcoin we can get to
why but would you buy the bitcoin uh
mining stocks because there's cash flow
no why first of all wait why first of
all
it's a cat coin mining stocks first of
all let's
like like look they don't mind anything
there's no mining equipment there they
solve math problems
but the problem is they use a lot of
energy to solve those problems
uh but i wouldn't want to buy any of
these things because when the price of
bitcoin crashes
these stocks are worthless because it's
going to cost more to mine them
than you could get for them so no i mean
if i
what i would be doing if i was a company
i would be selling stock to any fool
who's going to buy it from me i'd be
like
selling new shares doing secondaries you
know just trying to dump all it out
there if i
but i don't have any shares what would
it take for you to buy bitcoin what's
the one thing in the economy
or any sort of uh financial markets
that you would finally say all right
enough is enough i won't tell pomp that
he was right
but i'm gonna go put a little bitcoin
away i'm gonna put under the mattress
not tell anybody
well how much you talk about play money
like i would buy like you know a lottery
ticket or something but have you done
that yet
have you have you even speculated a
little bit bought even just one just for
fun
i mean you're not you're almost there i
haven't bought i have bought a couple of
lottery tickets in my life though
did you buy bitcoin as a lottery ticket
yet
no i haven't bought any bitcoin all
right so you haven't bought what would
cause you to have
given me people have given me some
bitcoin or fractions of a bitcoin but i
lost them all as you know
yeah so well you didn't lose something
you didn't lose
my son has actually bought some you
didn't lose the bitcoin you lost the
password which is user error i lost
access to them right i know where they
are
i know but i just can't i just can't get
at it
holding on to the bitcoin is an
intelligence test if you lose the
password it can't help you right
it's like losing the password to your
brokerage account sorry i never had the
password to lose that was a problem
all right what would it take to get you
to buy one bitcoin just one bitcoin
where you actually
took dollars and converted it into
bitcoin what would be the thing in the
market
that you would finally say all right i
gotta do this
well look right now they're what like 33
000 34 000. i never i wouldn't want to
waste 34
000 on a bitcoin so um
you know i mean i could buy a lot of
other things with that money i mean i
suppose if the price got
cheap enough maybe if it got back i
don't know below a buck maybe i could
buy one
but the question is you know would i
want one see this is the thing
i mean if you can say oh i i talked to a
lot of these bitcoin huddlers and
they're like oh yeah i would want to buy
so many more
really if it really got down that low
wouldn't that be a signal i mean is
there a point
you know for you bob you're asking me
when i would buy my bitcoin i mean i
don't really know because i i'm not
interested in it
but the real question is what will it
take to get you to sell
i mean goldwater if gold went to 500
would you buy more if gold went to 500
well sure okay but here's the reason why
because gold is an actual commodity is
it
and and so yes there's a lot of fake
gold i i want to talk to you about fake
gold i saw
there's all kinds of fake gold in space
yeah well so fake gold
doesn't do what real gold does i don't
know if you you know you yeah so
you know bill doesn't have the price how
do you know you have real gold
you like are you a chemist are you are
you testing it yeah
it's not you know that's part of the
lies that the bitcoin pumpers tell
is that it's hard to know real gold from
fake gold they've been able to tell
real gold from fake gold for thousands
of years and they didn't even have any
technology
they didn't even we it's so much easier
to tell the difference between real gold
and fake gold now
than we were on the gold standard so
this is all a bunch of nonsense
but to answer your question see since
gold is an actual commodity
let's say i am a jewelry manufacturer
and i i know i got demand to make
jewelry
which by the way is only is less than 10
of all demand
and demand for jewelry has been dropping
but go ahead
yeah i don't know i don't i don't know
who you're dating but anyway
so if the price of
gold goes down to 500 and i'm a jeweler
i'm like whoa
i can buy a bunch of gold that i need
much cheaper to make these necklaces or
these rings or these
whatever and so there's going to be more
demand right if i'm
if i need gold in my computer chips and
all of a sudden the price goes down now
i can buy more gold for the same money
and put them in my chips and save money
i'm going to buy more
right there's there's a way to
rationalize that like if i have a stock
i talked earlier about a stock
let's say there's a stock that i love at
ten dollars a share
and it's got a five percent dividend
yield at ten dollars a share
if the stock drops to five and now i got
and now
you know or it had a five percent
dividend and now it gets cut in half
and now the dividend is ten percent i
get twice the dividend yield
by buying it at half the price whatever
value of the assets was there
all else being equal i can buy those
same assets
for half price when it comes to bitcoin
i don't get any more
when i buy bitcoin at 10 000 than when i
buy it at 30 000. yeah i buy
i get more bitcoin but i don't get any
more dividends because it doesn't pay
any dividends
i don't get any more rent like i buy
real estate on sale
and i can't make any more jewelry
because i've got more bitcoin because
you can't make anything with a bitcoin
doesn't matter how many you have i can
have all 21 million bitcoins
and i can't do anything that i couldn't
do with just one
doesn't matter how many you have but the
more gold you have the more electricity
you can conduct the more jewelry you can
make whatever all that stuff you could
do
uh and so there is no way to know that
bitcoin is cheap because there's nothing
to measure it against so my question to
you is
you think bitcoin is going to be the new
money it's going to you know replace
gold
or replace other somewhere clear it's
already
financials
gold for people under the age of 35.
nobody owns a node under the age of 35.
it hasn't replaced gold in the real
world
it hasn't replaced gold in jewelry it
has a
the central banks still own gold as part
of a monetary asset they don't want net
sellers in q4 go ahead
but you believe that all this stuff is
going to happen to bitcoin
and it all hinges on you know
more adoption you know just like we
talked about social security being a
ponzi scheme it's kind of the same
dynamic
you're talking you're talking about gold
right gold price only goes up if more
people want gold right
not how it works people want gold for
all the properties that gold has
but but it's demand-based the only
reason hold on the only reason why any
asset goes up is because it's
demand-based
if more people don't know apple stock it
goes down if more people don't want gold
it goes down if more people don't want
bitcoin it goes down that's how the
markets work it's called supply
demand they'll send you economics if
people want to buy
apple products and apples earning a
profit
and paying a dividend well people will
want to buy the stock
now you know obviously in a different
environment with higher interest rates
they may not be willing to pay as much
for apple stock as they're paying now
but there will be demand at some price
for apple stock that's not the case with
bitcoin i mean at gold
even if you don't want to buy gold at
1800 you might want to buy it at a
thousand
because it may be a good deal for what
you needed for
but bitcoin is is not a commodity and
it's not
an investable asset it doesn't it
doesn't have a use and it doesn't throw
off an income stream
so get to get back to the question i'm
asking you
you think that bitcoin is going to
continue to
be adopted and more institutions are
going to buy it
more people around the world are going
to start using it what if that doesn't
happen right
at some point so let's say bitcoin
crashes to
to 20 000 or then 10 000 or then 5 000
right is there some point where you like
kind of like
all right i was wrong it's not catching
on the momentum has turned
i'm just going to give up on this i'm
not going to go down with the ship
to zero is there a point where you get
out
i mean what if unicorns fall from the
sky right no no no no
no that's a crazy thing if it continues
if it continues
going to 10 000 is not crazy bitcoin was
at ten thousand a year ago
to say that bitcoin can't go back to ten
thousand again is ridiculous well you're
my
point hold on if it does bitcoin change
your view so bitcoin was ten thousand a
year ago
and now it's at 35 and for bitcoin to go
from 35 to 10
about 70 75 whatever the number is right
yeah i'm sorry that means that we would
just return to prices not seen since
last year
if google fell 75 it would be
numbers from literally 30 years ago no
it wouldn't change my mind here's why i
wouldn't change my mind ready
everything that you say about the
economy i think generally you and i
agree
right we agree that the uh feds lost
their mind they're manipulating markets
uh people are getting hurt nobody
understands that they should be
investing rather than saving all the
things that you say about the economy we
agree on
you and i both also agree that sound
money
is the solution right we can't have
money that can just be printed at will
because politicians or other folks
decide that we're going to do that
or we're going to manipulate those
markets and so sound money is the
solution
right bitcoin doesn't qualify for money
well okay well just so we're clear
their sound money is the definition of
sound money is that it's outside the
system and no one can create more of it
and so gold course of all let me bump
do you know the origin of the word sound
money do you know where it comes from
it's not a spelling bee but go ahead
tell me well so if you take
a gold coin and you drop it on a hard
surface
it makes a sound as opposed to when you
drop a piece of paper on a surface
it doesn't make a sound so hard money
makes a sound when you drop
it what's the sound that bitcoin makes
when you drop it
peter do you hear anything this is like
blockbuster saying to netflix oh you
have no value because when we drop the
vhs tape on the table it makes a sound
that's ridiculous there's a difference
see see when i can watch a video that
still has value
i watching a video on television i mean
on the internet let's do a race all
right
we're going to set it up because we're
going to block we got to go in a minute
we got to go in a minute we're going to
make anything with bitcoin here's my
challenge to you
here's my challenge to you ready you
want to see what has more value
you send me a gold bar i'll send you a
bitcoin and we'll see who gets there
first
and that's irrelevant because i can
first of all i don't have any bitcoin to
send you no you send me the gold bar the
goal i mean you could put it in the mail
it'll take you seven days to get it yeah
but i would be sending you something
real the reason it's so cheap to send
bitcoin is because you're sending
nothing
if i'm gonna send nothing yeah i can
send nothing real cheap
but come back to this question i'm
asking you right
at where do you throw in the towel
on bitcoin and say no you're wrong
get rid of it i mean if it's not 10 000
what if it goes to 1 000
if bitcoin is at one thousand if we're
doing an interview
in the future and bitcoin is one
thousand
are you going to say well if you bought
it when it was a dollar you still have a
thousand times your money
peter the better performing or are you
gonna admit you were wrong
the the difference is that bitcoin is
going to be the global reserve currency
because nobody can create more of it and
it is already becoming the digital
reserve currency of that digital economy
and the whole key to this is the reason
why you're so worried about
price is because gold will never be the
global reserve currency ever again it's
over
we're not going back to a gold standard
but there is a much higher
likelihood that we transition to a
bitcoin reward
uh reserves uh status and when that
happens
the us dollar exchange value doesn't
matter
right it doesn't matter because just one
bitcoin equals one bitcoin
here here's the problem with the gold
thesis is that they printed trillions of
dollars
every asset in the planet literally
beanie babies
went up in value and gold didn't go up
in value in the last 12 months
yes so gold why is worth less than it
was last year
because it didn't even keep up with
inflation if i was holding gold
my gold didn't even keep up with
inflation yeah that's because
we have a bubble in everything gold is
money right
so you have a bubble stocks are
overpriced
real estate is overpriced in terms of
money gold is not currency
gold is actual money currency was backed
by money
the first legitimate currency was a
receipt for gold gold was the money that
backed up the currency
that's what gave currency value was that
it was backed up by gold
now fiat currency is currency backed up
by nothing
that's like what bitcoin is bitcoin is
backed by nothing it has no actual value
when you say that they're not you know
they there's a limit to how many
there's almost 11 000 cryptocurrencies
now i mean the supply is growing
uh you know like wildflower there is no
limit to the number
of virtually identical cryptocurrencies
that can be created and they keep
creating them and you think there's a
limit to 21 million bitcoin maybe there
is maybe there isn't it doesn't even
matter
how many bitcoins there are it matters
is how many other
cryptocurrencies could people buy
instead of bitcoin because there's
nothing special about bitcoin
other than the name and it's not even
that special because you got bitcoin
cash you got bitcoin gold you got
whatever bitcoin is bitcoin that i mean
what's the difference there's really
there really is no difference when you
basically you know take a step back and
look at
looking into god the the odds of bitcoin
becoming the reserve
asset for the world are zero it's never
going to happen that's a fantasy
peter i love you i just want to remind
you of one fact as your friend because i
feel like it's important that you
remember this
if you had sold your gold and bought
bitcoin
in the last 12 months or when you first
heard about it you'd be a billionaire
today
well there's look if i had put all of my
net worth
into bitcoin when i first heard about it
yeah
it's not your old net worth just you had
replaced your gold allocation with
bitcoin allocation yes i would i would
be a billionaire if i did that when i
first heard about it there's a lot of
or if you did it in the last year you'd
probably still be that applies but that
applies to a lot of people
not just me probably applies to you when
you first heard about bitcoin if you put
all your money in it you'd probably be a
billionaire too
no i'm not talking about all your money
i'm talking about just gold all right
before i let you go i appreciate you
coming on while you're on vacation nice
hotel you got a nice shirt hair combed
looking great
where should we send people what's your
twitter account where do you want us to
send people
well you know my twitter account is half
the size of yours you know i'm
you know you've got over a million
followers now but i know a year ago i
think i had more than you or
something two years ago bitcoin left
gold in the dust and i left you in the
dust
yeah yeah but you know what i'll you
know just let's see what happens over
the next few years you know
but uh where can we follow me on you can
follow me on twitter peter schiff i
finally got verified so maybe i'll do
better now
that i got the check mark
i had to get i had to get more than 500
000
followers before they verified me yeah
well you say crazy stuff on the internet
so they had to make sure that you
weren't a you know conspiracy theory
account or something
yeah well you know all right listen
thank you so much for doing this
people should listen to my podcast uh
at shiftradio.com or subscribe to my
youtube channel the shift report
we get a lot of uh listeners there i'm
even doing my podcasts
from uh from here in switzerland shift
radio is the best idea
of the best business show i did the last
one from italy we were in i we were in
uh lake como over the weekend and i did
my last podcast
you're like an international traveler
you're just like a globetrotter jet
setter kobe is gone peter is off in the
sky
yeah yeah i know i mean well people
still have masks on around so it's a
little frustrating but
most people are de-masked all right
all right well thanks for doing this
most important thing though
is that you know if you got some money
hey look if you got some bitcoin
you should take some profits even if
look you know you got people like my kid
my son is like
i'm never gonna sell any bitcoin well
what i mean so what good is that you're
going to die with your bitcoin if you're
never going to sell them you're never
going to make any money i mean at least
take something off the table sell into
the rallies you can always
buy it back you know if you you like it
so much wait for the next dip and buy
that but
you know take some something off the top
that's that's some good advice
and bitcoin is at a minimum anthony
right
bitcoin is very speculative you've got
to admit that it's this is all a
speculation it's a crapshoot
right and if you're right that bitcoin
is going to go to a million or a billion
a little bit of bitcoin will go a long
way breaking news
breaking news peter schiff just said
that bitcoin may go to a billion dollars
whatever right so just keep a little bit
of money in bitcoin
the rest of the money you can send it to
me to manage for you because at least
you know you're not going to lose that
you know you're going to get some good
solid stocks you know get get some
income
you can even buy bitcoin with your
dividends you know if you want to do
that
you want to get a nice dividend
portfolio and you want to take your
dividend checks that i'm sending you
and you want to waste some of that
income on bitcoin you know
at least you're going to get more right
the dividends are going to keep coming
so you know contact some of my reps and
i know i see some people like in my
neighborhood in puerto rico
because the real estate has literally
gone up at least 4x
since i moved there and part of the
reason is all these bitcoin guys
cashing out their bitcoin and buying up
houses you know
so listen they just want to live near
you you're a wealth of knowledge they
just want to be close so that they can
tell you i told you so once uh once
everything happens but listen
well you can already say that now you
can say i told you so because bitcoin is
at
thirty three thousand thirty four
thousand but in a year or two maybe less
i'm gonna be saying i told you so when
you because you didn't sell
maybe right i'm gonna be i told you so
you should have sold i mean look at that
chart anthony take a look at that
bitcoin chart
and that thing could collapse i mean
look at where you are you're up in the
stratosphere here
with this massive head and shoulders top
there's no support there beneath that
neckline
this thing can implode even quicker you
know there's an old saying about markets
right they take the
the stairs up and the elevator down
right well
bitcoin they're even gonna take the
elevator you're just jumping right off
the top of the building you're just free
falling all the way down
elevator is gonna be slow compared to
how bitcoin goes down
all right all right all right enjoy your
vacation we'll talk soon thank you so
much for joining us
all right all right anthony all right
bye buddy all right guys
that's it i got joe and john we're
signing off i don't know we don't have
some kind of cool ending yet we'll come
up with one
but uh we appreciate you tuning in for
uh for the first show there's joe and
john
oh little oh a little fist bump okay
maybe that was a lot to do
how do you know they're joe and john
well they got their names on the backs
of their chairs
you'll never forget they don't realize
the camera's on them but there you go
now move
hey there we go joe and john we'll see
you guys tomorrow 11
a.m eastern thanks for tuning in to the
first show make sure you like
the video so that this goes viral on
youtube make sure that you subscribe to
the channel so you get a notification
every time we go live
if you're on twitter make sure that you
hit the retweet button use
best business show so we can find them
and
if you want go to
thebestbusinessshow.com go buy
the day one merch only available through
the end of july
if you buy it we'll know you were here
day one if not i'm not gonna believe you
be quiet don't tell me you there day one
go get the day one shirt the best
business show.com we'll see you guys
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign